[Musica]
volete testare l'audio testate l'audio
piselli bravo avevo tutti i ragazzi non
credete a tutti ragazzi benvenuti questo
video sarò fa vj e oggi siamo su un
gioco bello di macchine che si deve
usare l'acceleratore sono con xbox live
e 12 tu scusa e l'altro ditelo voi vi
prego io mi ricordo come ti chiami sarà
mica uno che inizia con lei e finisce
con buffon siamo anche con ai foo foo
che in realtà si chiama law che però è
brava e rotaia il buffo hanno appena
aggiornato tipo rocket league adesso e
hanno messo delle mappe nuove tipo
questa facciamo tipo 1 contro due io e
micky contro luca tanto la prendiamo con
diawara giovanni va ragioni e le
illustro brevemente st mappe circolare
che vuol dire che che puoi passare anche
attraverso la porta dell'avversario
sbucare nella nostra capitale dove devo
fare gol
quella di fare gol nella porta di luca
che sennò perdiamo e lebole [ __ ] non
in quella che ormai siamo forti e luca
ormai non puoi pini ma che casuale lunga
quanto sei scarso come persona e non mi
e non mi domanda siamo sono carico è
stata poi piace lei mi chiaramente il
figlio dai che tanto odio
vai vai a preoccupare no plein di
aprilia prenderla
faccio il giro faccio il giro si no
c'ero quasi è fissato il brivido della
parata inclinati vado cattivissimo
guardati la a spuntare dal nulla invece
lo mancata di brutto grave di questa
cosa delle porte circolari serve due
sessi queste cose ci dà la caccia a luca
non è vero
non è vero ma che cazzo sei battaglie le
importa che sia queste gol queste cose
ti devi togliere luca stai
no no no no no gg ma va bene perché la
metà una foto di luca sullo schermo che
se lo vedete per strada la dovete
picchiata ehi ehi ehi vai vai comodo
comodo è volata farà il volo che prende
lui ha in mente come la sofferta ha
scelto e va beh ciao ciao luca ciao ciao
luca cars poiché ti diamo un giocatore
per avere bambini per la potenza del
culo segna segna segna 32 m
di queste il gol tuo non te lo voglio
lasciare torino
[Musica]
mi spiace ha abbandonato la faccio
lucarelli chiquita trasmetti l'altro dai
dai ho vinto il top per di del mouse
io mi metto blu voi fate gli arancioni
ok ok tu devi vincere se vinco io boh
non lo so e sentivano way londra luca
vive su questo gioco non mangia neanche
quindi lei era vero ma tutti gold
picazio è questo bellissimo il ragazzo
in a 0 7 secondi dalla partenza di kimi
che mi rompe con andré che lui ha dato a
un picco di ogni aiuto capuana nichi
quanto ti odio la madre che si dice
retta via
l'aj non vale una cena con la min koo la
lega le guarda sei una merda lì dai da
hill's importo di sport markt vabbè a
non solo mettete qualcuno anche sulle
fasce [ __ ] nichi ti odio no no non
aver ascoltato i ragazzi fermi tardi
pugnale ho detto pugno male ma
tracciavano una scarpa slacciata milano
spicca colini ovvero numerico più zucca
intanto dipendi sto gol male dai rischi
[ __ ] [ __ ] anche qui ci manca solo
quello sì vabbè ragazzi non è possibile
posso mai vincere secondo mi dirà le
capocciate kakà va bene non lo faccio
più va beh allora sono un pazzo non di
queste pallonetto sombrero più pallone
[Musica]
ad iron team polacco mi ha fatto cioè
non prenderla sta cazzo di palla guarda
che gol
no perché colgo luca non è vero non è
vero come cazzola talk la miche io sono
demoralizzati store ha ricambiato o
attenzione molto della vendetta
nichi devi togliere buffalo state tirate
un pallonetto è mica sei andato troppo
alte ma se riuscite a parare due festa
si va bene facciamo l'ultima io te
contro di lui di mammoni chi è chiamato
l'acqua questa questo nichi 6 entra un
gol non mi parlare più tutte la bella
guarda guarda dove luca guarda come
cazzo fa essere qui siamo in due
come fai come spazio di mare siamo in
due
dai dati ma se mettiamo tipo 50 euro a
testa e una pistola c'e la compriamo
secondo c'è su amazon la fanno a
spedizione veloce veloce tra parlo nella
spedizione entro tre minuti e 40 secondi
aspetta aspetta aspettano che mi sono
capitate come il cimici i signori e
signori un cazzo perché quello ovunque
tira tira tira tira never è nella nostra
porta che siamo in due perché siamo 3 a
1 per lui che siamo in due valori queste
cose queste che non puoi sbagliare ma
non c'era quasi per nichi tutta la
potenza che c'hai tutta la potenza che
c'hai tutte le mezzo buttare in mezzo
come cazzo noia rivincita se vi state
facendo delle domande sul perché mi
chiamo sigis è perché sigis e
l'abbreviativo di sigismondo al mio tre
dovete premere tutti ics x8 quello per
andare
123 a a e invece ho adesso vuoi vedere
che inizia a far schifo perché giochi
con melo è un presupposto per scelta
faccio io faccio io faccio io faccio io
faccio io è vero territorio perché non
ti non chiamati demolita plasmato fuoco
[Musica]
sì ma non si può fare un quattro contro
quattro le cleva trump art al chi
symbian che cazzo è super mario e vabbè
vabbè poi non ci stà manco nello schermo
il nome volley claver tram parts indian
ma che cazzo di numero potrà chiamarsi
sigis ragazzi qualcuno ha dato un
cavallo a quest'uomo che gli si è
infilato direttamente nel culo così
forfait m
vabbè dai ma sempre questo ma chi cazzo
neo le creava mi fai la intro del canale
bravo abbiamo perso però si vabbè ma
abbiamo perso contro sta giocando la
sony che quanti punti ha fatto a impatto
zero punti ma mai fatto niente per che
stavi fermo era uguale noi capita ma il
bello è che sono tutto per ragazzi
questa è l'altra nuova non lo sappiamo
però che cos'è perché l'hanno aggiunte
praticamente adesso mentre stavamo
giocando vabbè la prima locale abbiamo
fatto il culetto vuoi giocare da solo te
la senti quali
arancione la fortuna ci stiamo a pasta
nissim e se ci fossero tre pali 20 gol
vabbè non è vero che lo aveva lasciato
joystick angelis ho creduto di quale
droga
esattamente ti sei fatto nel quale quei
dati né cronologico ma va bene così
avevo già le [ __ ] incamera ragazza
ma se abbiamo fatto 16 gol perché qui
siamo due pari
by loris sono mangiati va bene abbiamo
lavorato a the man 12 niente devo dei
deficienti tanto non arriva tanto non
arrivata bravissimo nichi bravissimo
nikita lo tolgo guardingo le tue non
riferita dai di chi te l'ha detto che
volevo era da me le invento gianluca
jean orgasmici grazie grazie di ragazze
grazie luca grazie non entrava mai sono
alla fine vita
cf no no no no natoli natalino torino
torino dal titolo di che pericolosissimo
dagli la da lì no non è vero non è vero
come è vero
gli ultimi 10 secondo anni fido più a
segnare subito ma che cazzo vuoi fare
segna ti prego che non può vincere
quest'uomo valori lasciando no perché
hai mai khatami e che non a caso lì
spero che video vi sia piaciuto spero
che anche voi adesso c'eravate con luca
per il fatto ma anche luca marin a tutti
che cosa dite cose veramente figo mickey
è bellissima e quindi ragazzi spero che
sia piaciuto chi è che luca che sbuffa è
merito mi piace è se vedete che si trova
setacciato momento è un mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook con i video
trattenere al tizian date un bel ciao
mentre ceco lo telecomanda questo
momento fa sentire come sei contento
luca dc ciao luca avvertito che ci
vediamo così belle ragazze
ciao